what are the crazier crowds you've ever
seen
how was yeah paul's been wanting to ask
you about woodstock yeah you had
woodstock 99 which i know was kind of
like
infamously sort of a [ __ ] show no not
our day okay our day was amazing um
we went on and it was an amazing show
the first show was was um
it's one of the highlights of my whole
career i've never seen that many people
and everybody was having a good time and
there was no [ __ ] going on that
night
it just got progressively worse because
the the situation out there water was
ten bucks the outhouses were overfilling
and [ __ ]
pisses everywhere um it got really
really bad out there so i understand why
everybody got pissed and start writing
it wasn't a good
setup but for our our night was amazing
i remember flying over there we all
rented a jet we got this big
it was a 737 it was us biscuit
and and ice cube and we all got on this
plane and we all rolled
all to woodstock that was fun the party
on that thing was ridiculous there was
like the crew and everybody in the back
there was this midsection which cube had
and we're all playing craps in there
and it was all gangsters there and then
there was the front section which is my
section because i like it
cool and just chill so i'd walk back
there play some crafts and walk
up to the front where i could just relax
and there was no craziness going on but
i mean that
show was man it was nuts there's
so many people and i'll never forget
that show
and you were you were like a year sober
then right
yeah and i'd been i think a year
99 yeah i was a year sober and i was
still i didn't know i was going through
dts i was still going through
just like i kicked a cold turkey i mean
i stopped
i'd shake and have anxiety attacks and
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
um in my bunk that whole process i
didn't know that
you go through this stuff so i thought i
was just going crazy but i got in there
and i did it and i went
back and i couldn't even move because
we'd been in the studio working on a
record
we even played songs at that show that
had no lyrics i was freestyling just
mumbling
um some of the songs it was it was great
but after that
i went back and i they had to carry me
back in the dressing room and i just
i was dying i was in pain i hadn't moved
like that in years
and it was it was rad then the next day
we got on plane went home
it was a good time yeah dude